blade Smiths welcome to the forge
gentlemen in this first round of Greek
mythology inspired competition we're
going to give you three hours to force
signature blades in your signature style
using a go my or five layer technique
using these gifts from the god hefestus
the weapon Smith of the
Gods this armor these hammers lightning
bolts and these medallions must be used
some of this is high carbon steel some
of its mild steel it's up to you to
determine what's
what good luck gentlemen your 3- hours
starts now so the hammer seems like it's
some degree hardenable I test the
lightning bolts and they seem really
good but I just don't have a lot of that
steel I'm trying to weigh all this in my
mind as far as what do I go for I'm
still very much in preliminary stage
kind of figuring out how I'm going to
attack
this I'm taking some steel and I'm going
to quench it in the oil then I put it in
the vice and then hit it with my hammer
if it's not high carbon steel it's going
to fold it's going to bend it's going to
roll whereas if the steel hardens and
you hit it with a hammer while it's in
that Vice it's going to snap and give
you a look at the Grain on the inside
the Quench and snap to check the steel
is more thorough but the spark test is a
lot faster it's a challenge definitely
figuring out what I'm doing here I'm
still trying to come up with my game
plan I want to use the hammer for for
the core of the knife Dave's out there
cutting up a hammerhead good for him
it's a lot of mass so I should be able
to draw it out and get the main body of
the
knife and then basically doing like a
double sanmai or taco technique take the
lightning bolt bend it around the spine
get that to forge weld then take the
mild steel and wrap it around the back
of that and then Forge weld it giving me
five
layers you have only 2 hours remaining
to finish your work the clock is picking
and I'm having a hard time picking out
what I'm going to do I didn't think I'd
be this indecisive but there's a lot on
the line Robert's spending a lot of time
with his setup so I'm hoping he's
setting himself up for success I need to
make a decision and I need to do it
quick so I decide to go hammer in the
center medallions on the outside of that
and then I've got my lightning bolts I'm
going to weld all these together and
hope for the
best I tested both the hammer and then
the the lightning bolt they both were
hardened the armor for me it just bent
over when I tried to harden it I decid
I'm going to go with a hammer in the
middle the liting bolts on the side and
the armor on the side of that I'm going
to tack weld all this stuff together and
then cut it with the
saw and cut all the overhang off to
where I've got a solid Billet the most
important thing is to have a hardenable
steel in the middle that way you get a
strong Edge it looks like all of our SPS
have done that what I decid to do was
was I cut two small rectangles of armor
tack welded them to the blade and then
brought the knife up to forge blood
temperature and very very gently set the
weld next step is draw that Billet out
and then I'm going to start forming it
into a knife it does look good he's done
a good job lining everything
up all right Robert time to draw that
Billet out I was kind of indecisive in
the beginning and I wasted a little bit
of time and I feel that's really biting
me in the ass right now at this point
with the time that I've got left it's
big blue
time you still got to quench that and
then get to the grinder and then into
the acid end if you think you can't make
a knife in half an hour you can't if you
got big
blue my Blade's straight tank straight
I'm ready to quench
it oh
quench I think he's got a good straight
blade I look it's perfectly straight
it's good it looks like Jared has like
the most complete and performance- built
blade now it's it's game time I got to
get on the grinder and get the thing
cleaned
[Music]
up I finished shaping as best as I can
got to lean that blade is Dave's got got
to make sure he doesn't grind off that
thin layer of armor on the outside only
got like 12 minutes left I need to get
this blade heat treated ow man that
sucker is hot big Fireball almost lose
the beard woo it's still here though so
that's
good my plan is to get something done
that meets the parameters for that clock
hits
zero good quinch I don't hear any pings
the welds seem like they did okay so
I've got to go straight to the
grinder I start shaving Material
off 25 seconds now I've got to etch this
thing it is right down to the wire 5 4 3
two one BL Smith shut down your machines
drop your tools this first round of
competition is
over all right gentlemen it's time for
the strength test the Greek armor stab
we're not screwing around today so I'm
definitely putting on a glove now this
test is not about what your blades do to
that armor it's about what the armor
does to your blades now Robert you're up
first you ready yes
sir these edges aren't rolled over at
all they're a hard angle as opposed to
being rounded over I mean there's a dent
in my thumb and anything that comes in
contact with the hand really should be
rounded off no you've got a good Edge
everywhere but right here which took
most of the impact when I chopped into
that armor but here's the ne thing your
tip is still a sharp as it was the
knife's solid it's all together good job
thank you Jared you're up next you ready
yes
sir
[Music]
first off you've got a super aggressive
point on this which still sharp and
still there so your Edge held up
beautifully it's still solid it's in one
piece I think you did a good job thank
you all right Dave it's up to you you
ready no but let's do it okay
really worried right now essentially it
turned into be just a mess of scraps
that I was able to slam together to
roughly resemble a handle just to get
something done in
[Music]
time just run your finger right there
hey D you finish it and put it on the
anle good job nice man as soon as Dave
picked up the knife started walking
towards the other judges I know this is
just not good I'm hoping that they're
going to test it so I can at least you
know see what my Blade's made of but at
this point I'm not
sure Dave there's a problem
unfortunately your guard is actually
cutting the leather glove that Dave was
going to use for safety and the judges
have given your weapon a vote of no
confidence and we cannot continue to
test a blade that is deemed unsafe to
the user for that reason I'm going to
invite you to shake our hands and then
exit the forge come on forward my
friend thank you not the forge and fire
Champion but I'm still going to keep
pursuing my crafts it's what I love to
do and I'm only going to get better with
time wish I would have got to see the
judges test the weapon but I understand
safety comes first you know Famous Last
Words five more
[Music]
minutes